and so in that where do you think crypto
assets sit in a traditional capital
allocators portfolio how are they
thinking about that right now yeah so I
just put out some some content around
this and hopefully in the next few days
we'll push out a longer report with a
lot of great data in it look if we look
at this institutional investor class
there's about in the u.s. there's about
28 trillion dollars of institutional AUM
and that's mostly pensions but that's
endowments family offices hedge funds
venture funds PE firms crypto market cap
is 220 250 billions or on daily basis
right now and so what I what I think is
challenging is right now those those
firms are allocating to low-risk
securities right so t-bills strips bonds
etc that's a small percent of their
portfolio they've cash money market
stuff they have traditional equities
they have real estate and then maybe 15%
of their portfolio is in higher risk
assets that focus on early stage capital
formation the growth stage capital
formation so that's growth equity and PE
it's hedge funds and it's venture and so
as we look at that where do crypto
assets fit in monetary instruments
probably the closest analogue to
something like a Bitcoin okay so that's
more like your money market bucket real
estate that's probably more like
securitized assets right so can we
securitize assets and make them more
flexible maybe equities that's more like
token offerings that represent equity
and privately held companies write that
kind of displace is that PE bucket I
SEOs probably fit more into the VC
bucket where it's really early stage
idea is getting capitalized so that I'm
trying to think of in the context of an
institutional investor is what are those
analogs because they think there may be
new capital that flows in but likely
it's more of a displacement of existing
allocations into some of these new asset
classes and I think what's challenging
there is you have to frame the narrative
in a way
an institutional investor a understands
what they're buying it fits into the
mental models they have that have been
trained you know over the last 50 years
and then they also have to be able to
hold it trade it deal with it talk about
it to their investors in an easy way and
I think that's where the market
infrastructure side is a little immature
we've been so focused on the creation
and distribution of assets that we
really haven't started thinking about
the management of assets so that post
investment lifecycle is pretty
underdeveloped and then end-of-life of
an asset right so what happens when a
token is dead how do you redeem a token
back into cash what do you get so
there's gonna be a lot of
experimentation but I think the slice of
the pie that's gonna go into
cryptocurrencies true store value crypto
currencies I SEOs security tokens and
securitized assets is initially going to
be much smaller than we imagined but
then when we start being able to prove
that in fact that efficiency that
liquidity and that sort of usability
component that we talked about can
actually be realized once there's proof
of that
I think it'll grow much more quickly but
we're not doing a very good job right
now